christina
hallo oma wie geht es dir
gut und dir
ja mir auch
was machst du am samstag
am samstagmorgen
ich einkaufe
dann räume ich meine wohnung auf
am samstagmorgen
ich einkaufe
dann räume ich meine wohnung auf
fragst du
ich mache am samstagnachmittag eine
grillparty
es kommen alle kollegen aus dem
deutschkurs
kommst du auch
super ja gerne
kann ich auch am sonntag aufräumen
meine wohnung kann ich auch am sonntag
aufräumen
um wie viel uhr
wir fangen um 14 uhr an
ok und wo ist die party
bei mir zu hause
meine adresse ist bächlein straße 15
einen moment ich notiere
das
bächle
straße 15
einen moment ich notiere
das
becht
straße 15
kann ich etwas mitbringen
bring eine wurst dort ein stück fleisch
für dich mit
ich mache für alle einen
art
ich kaufe auch getränke ein
wenn du möchtest kannst du einen kuchen
backen
wo ich kann leider nicht gut backen
hoch ich kann leider nicht gut backen
aber ich kann einen kuchen kaufen
ja das ist auch gut
ok
vielen dank für die einladung
ok vielen dank für die einladung
bitte gern geschehen ich freue mich sehr
[Musik]
ich mich auch
bis samstag
ja bis dann
tschüss
der/die oder dass der/die oder das
karotte
die karotte
die karotten
die k
die karotten burka
die gurke
die gurken die gurke
die gurken salat der salat
dies erwarte der salat
die salate aubergine die aubergine
die oberschicht
die aubergine
die auberginen erbse
dr
die erbsen die erbse
die erbsen kürbis
der kürbis
die kürbisse der kürbis
wisse
vier sich der pfirsich
die pfirsiche der pfirsich die pfirsiche
melone
die melone
die melonen
mehr lohnen
ananas
diana
die aok
[Musik]
die avocados
die avocado
ne
die birne
die birnen
zitrone
die zitrone
die zitronen die zitrone
die zitronen kirche die kirche
die kirchen die kirche
die kirschen erdbeeren die erdbeere
die erdbeeren die erdbeere
die erdbeeren kiwis
die ki
die
die kiwis
u
der tod
der tofu
[Musik]
das fleisch
münchen
das höhe
das hü
der fisch
speck
der speck
pfeffer
der pfeffer
salz
das salz
das öl
essig
der essig
flasche
die flasche
die flaschen
die flaschen hast du eine frage schreibt
eine frage in die kommentare
wir werden sie beantworten hast du eine
frage schreibt eine frage in die
kommentare wir werden sie beantworten
habt ihr das video gefallen abonniere
unseren kanal hat dir das video gefallen
abonniere unseren kanal